Thank you.
Now the shipping forecast issued by the Met Office
on behalf of the Maritime and Coast Guard Agency
at 5:05 on Friday,
the 4th of July.
There are warnings of gales in Fitzroy, Shannon,
Rockwall, Malin and Hebrides.
The general synopsis at midnight, Atlantic
low 997, moving rather
quickly eastwards,
expected Pharaohs, 998
by midnight tonight.
Low, Iberia, 1016,
slow moving with little change.
The area forecast for the next 24 hours.
Viking, south or southwest, 4
to 6, becoming cyclonic 3 to 5
later. Rain or showers,
good, occasionally poor.
North at irra, south atirra, southerly
or southwesterly, 4 to 6.
Rain or showers, good, occasionally
poor. 40s
chromaty 4th Tyne dogger.
West, 4 to 6, backing southwest,
5 to 7.
Occasional rain,
good, occasionally moderate.
Fisher, German Bight
West or southwest, 4 to 6.
Showers, rain later, good, occasionally
moderate later.
Hi everyone, good morning, thank you for joining us for
this session.
Uh, my name's Ed Steele, I'm IT Fellow
for Data Science at the Met Office, the
UK's National Weather Service. And what
you've just listened to is the shipping
forecast, the world's oldest
and longest running forecast, in
this case, on the anniversary of its broadcast
of its centenary earlier this year.
This is a cornerstone of regional
maritime safety and a British
cultural institution.
It's issued by the Met Office on behalf
of the Maritime Coast Guard Agency, the MCA,
and it's broadcast to mariners 4 times
a day via Navtex
and via BBC Radio 4
as well.
The forecast, as you've just heard an excerpt
of, uh, comprises predicted
conditions for 31 different
sea areas
that must be analyzed by human meteorologists
and condensed into text sentences
with a very specific length
and format,
following a very specific
and strict set of rules.
So the shipping forecast
itself though,
is really a pioneer in
the communication of meteorological
information. And it can and it can trace its
roots back to October 1859,
when the steam clipper, the Royal Charter,
foundered in a violent storm off the west coast
of the UK.
Over 450 lives
were lost associated with just this ship
alone, and the storm itself
went on to claim at least a further
800 lives in total, and
133 ships were lost,
with a further 90 badly
damaged.
The founder of the Met Office,
Admiral Robert Fitzroy, as a direct result
of this,
introduced the first,
uh, British storm warning service
for shipping
in February 1861.
And in appreciation of the valuable help
from, uh, the meteorological Service,
um, by the radio reports that were
received from ships, a weather bulletin
called Weather Shipping
was started, and this became,
uh, the shipping forecast as we know
today. So
fast forward to present times and the Met Office
continues to push the boundaries of science and
technology, helping people make better
decisions to stay safe and thrive
by delivering the most trusted weather
and climate intelligence in a radically
changing world.
We're one of the few, if not the only
organizations in the world that crosses a huge diversity
of boundaries,
covering weather and climate across
all timescales,
drawing between science and services,
to both government,
industry, across civilian and military,
both nationally and internationally,
and predicting meteorology and extending
this now into hazards.
And this all happens in one place.
But actually pulling this together, a
recent report issued last year,
um, from an independent analysis
showed that the Met Office is
poised to deliver 56 billion
pounds of benefit to the UK economy
and society over the next 10 years.
And this gives a return on investment
from the taxpayer, um, in the
UK of 19 to 1
on our public money.
So a hugely important
organization and
service.
But what does a 100 year old forecast
have to do with AI?
Well, in this talk,
Dinesh and I are going to give an introduction
to weather forecasting.
We're going to talk about the last mile in weather
forecasting
before proceeding to talk about actually how we architect
these solutions, uh, to be able
to deliver these vital services.
We've conducted some unique experiments
er involving fine tuning of the Amazon
Nova Foundation model, which we'll present
some initial results from and talk
a bit about some of the evaluation of these
so that they can be adopted
er by other um
by other interested er groups.
So how does the Met Office forecast the weather?
Well, it first starts by understanding
what the weather is doing now.
So we're taking in observations from
all over the world. In fact, we're ingesting about
215 billion observations
every day that provide the starting
conditions for the numerical models that we run
to predict how the conditions are
going to evolve.
This takes place on our supercomputer,
um, where we're computing, using the equations
of motion, uh, the evolution
of those conditions, um,
using mathematical equations
um to uh to to then
give us a,
a prediction
of what the conditions are going to be.
The data from this is provided both
directly to some users, but also passed
to some of our operational meteorologists,
who add further value by interpreting
some of these complicated fields to
be able to distill this information into value
added services
for the public.
And finally, the accurate weather and climate
information is then is then shared
more broadly, benefiting all
of the different stakeholders with whom we worker
from defense right through to
aviation, er marine and
and others.
Now when you step back and think about it,
uh, weather forecasting is actually
a remarkable achievement.
And over the years, we've undergone
what's really termed a quiet a revolution
in terms of our ability to predict the weather.
So physics-based numerical models
have seen an improvement in accuracy of
between about half a day and 1
day per decade.
So for example, our forecast in 2013,
uh, 5 days ahead, was as accurate
as our forecast in
2003, for example,
uh, at 4 days ahead lead
time. And these improvements have
been driven by upgrades to the
observations and the assimilation of those
data. The dynamics and physical
representation of these processes
within the maths, and also
improvements in model resolution er
that have er been ongoing through
this time.
And these physics-based models
remain an essential component
of our forecasting um
approach. But
obviously it's remiss not to mention
er machine learning and the accompanying
AI revolution that we've er
experienced.
Now the Met Office has always been a big data
organization and AI and machine learning
activities have likewise always been ongoing
for many years, although these haven't
always been er perhaps
acknowledged under that specific label.
But undeniably,
advances in deep learning technologies
in particular, are really rewriting
the rules of entire industries and
including how we predict the weather
um as well.
And what's really brought us to this point
are the unprecedented volumes of data,
some of which from observations, some of which
from numerical predictions.
Increasing availability of powerful
er compute capacity,
including on services such as AWS
and then also equipping our expert
scientists with the data science
tools to really be able to exploit
these insights um and
er and information.
And the rise in machine learning weather models
has been relatively profound.
So what I'm showing here is a
graph showing the performance
on the Y axis of
a particular metric for
a data-driven model
as a function
of the lead time when it was published.
And the key threshold that we're looking at
is this blue line,
which is uh the reference level
of uh a physics-based
state of the art model.
And what we can see is that from
September 2017 onwards,
we're seeing. A steady rise in our ability
to predict weather conditions for a subset
of parameters
using entirely data-driven
processes, so involving
effectively pattern recognition rather
than directly solving the equations of motion.
Around this time in the Met Office, uh,
we were starting to formulate
some of our data science framework,
so we were keeping an eye on some of these developments,
but also laying out how we would develop
our own capabilities uh in
this deep learning space to complement
our physics-based approaches, but also
how we would work uh with partners
and evolve er some of our
people uh to support this.
But the world changed when we hit
December
2022.
And my boss often refers to this as the missing
Christmas,
because there was a stream of publications
of really exciting capability
around data-driven approaches
um in weather prediction that came out
literally uh between about
20th of December, um,
to, to the sort of Christmas period.
And what we can see importantly here
is that for the first time for some of these parameters,
then we're starting to see the performance of these
data-driven approaches exceeding
that of our physics-based
models.
And if we just look at some of the er
the references here, we can also
see that these exciting developments
were largely driven by some advances
er from the likes of DeepMind, from the likes
of Nvidia, from the likes of Huawei,
so not typical players, but being able
to exploit some of these data science capabilities.
However,
A forecast
only actually has value if
a user can derive some sort of
decision making benefit from it.
And so while we've had this er
really exciting development in, in the underpinning
er opportunities for predicting
what the weather will be in different
ways, actually, there's been remarkably
less attention
on what the weather is going to
do. And arguably this last
mile in weather forecasting, a bit
like in delivery, um, is actually
potentially even more significant
in terms of the opportunities for
adding,
Uh, value and adding benefit
for our users,
because it enables us to provide even more
personalized services. It enables
us to provide even more multi-modal
approaches, uh, for our data delivery,
so that we can have data and accompanying
narrative, uh, while reducing
some of the burden that currently these
processes are, are reliant on, on
human interpretation.
So we're super excited about some of this
stuff, and.
To articulate this, just with a single
product example, so in this case, uh
we're going to use the shipping forecast as an
example that you heard at the start.
We need to take the complicated data
that's output from our weather models
and turn this into text
at scale.
And this isn't necessarily a trivial problem
because these are very large arrays of data
that we're dealing with.
That span multiple dimensions,
including both in space and time,
but also span multiple parameters.
So not only, for example, pressure, as I've
shown here,
but also we heard things like sea state,
visibility,
weather, wind speed, wind direction,
and all of this has to be
framed within the very specific
and strict wording and format
of the shipping forecast.
So this was, this was the use case that
we're going to uh explore in more
detail here.
Now just to represent this in terms of some
of the technology challenges associated with
this, uh this is really just an
example demonstrator of
the types of products and services
that we're looking to transform using some of these technologies.
The reason the Shipping Forecast was chosen
was partly because it was iconic status,
but actually because it enables us to test
a variety of different
uh aspects and a variety
of different data characteristics.
So. The forecast itself and the
underpinning data comprises both
atmosphere and ocean model
output,
so for example, things like wind speeds, but also
wave heights.
The format of this data is both
probabilistic
and deterministic, depending on which
of those variables from which of the models
uh have been uh
been considered.
And it is multidimensional, so we're
considering
that spatial region, so latitude,
longitude and time.
And what's particularly exciting about this is
really some of the data volumes involved.
So considering just the output
from a single forecast
run from one of our one of our numerical
weather prediction models,
then we're typically generating upwards of 45
gigabytes of data per
individual forecast um from the atmospheric
models and about 5 gigabytes of data
per individual forecast, uh, from our
ocean models.
When we then
consider the shipping forecast, we're able to make some efficiencies
and we're able to uh crop this down
to just the particular variables that we need
and particular area that we're
considering, that Northwest European shelf
region. And this results in about
152 megabytes
for our atmospheric data and
about 7 megabytes
for our ocean data. But still
fairly large,
particularly considering when we're
considering fine tuning foundation
models, then this is about sort of 85
gigabytes of data
for a three month period.
An additional challenge from a data science perspective
is that some of the formats that we're using here
are based on net Network Comm form.
Uh, so this is largely an atmospheric and
an ocean convention.
Um, there are very good libraries for being able to,
to, to read this in, but it's,
I guess, not a typical form for that,
uh, many outside the weather community,
uh, will necessarily have, uh,
encountered, but it's quite a convenient form
because it's effectively
a pandas or X-array type, uh.
Format, uh, in, in memory.
So the solution that we were then exploring then
was could we provide
this information as output from our weather
models and then serve this
into
uh a large language model er
to be able to er to to
be able to actually write this text.
We were using both a combination of the Amazon
Nova Lite and the Nova Pro 1.0
models, uh,
two hadn't yet come out.
And just to frame, uh, this
task, it usually takes an expert
meteorologist a few hours a day to
produce this forecast.
And in just 4 weeks of prototyping with
the team at Amazon,
we taught Amazonova to do this with
between 52 and 62% accuracy
in less than 5 minutes.
So before I hand over to Dinesh, I
was just going to say a few words about the
process of how we, we went about this and
some of the
background, some of the experiments that we conducted.
So we're going to talk about two different approaches
that we, that we, uh, explored.
Both of which
start with taking the weather sensor
data and, uh, and
then that gets run with our models, both
deterministic and probabilistic models, to produce
outputs.
Those outputs are typically, as I say, very
large arrays, um, and those consi
consist of the raw input gridded
data. So we're dealing with latitude, longitude
and time in this.
Um, and we did for the large language model
implementation,
we interpreted these through a text intermediary,
so we're extracting statistics corresponding
to the different, uh, regions of
the shipping forecast, uh, itself,
as you heard at the start,
er, to summarize those and then pass
those into,
uh, the Nova LLM.
And this, uh, this really provides
us with a benchmark.
What we also explored, and a lot of the
focus of our experiments
was around using video capabilities of these
types uh types of model.
So that same gridded data was
first converted
and encoded to video.
Um, and this was done on a sea area
basis typically for most of the parameters.
And then we fine-tuned this using
the bulletins
that had been issued
previously by our meteorologists,
uh, to be able to uh interpret
these um as inputs. And
then that was hosted uh to enable
us to to then run inference
on that um in real time.
But to dive deeper into the
uh architecture of this, I'm gonna hand
over to to Dinesh uh to
talk about that.
Thank you so much, Ed.
Uh hello. Good morning. My name
is Ad Dinesh.
I'm based out of Luxembourg and I work
with Worldwide super tapping team.
I work as an applied scientist over there.
Before jumping into that, I want to ask a
question. How many of you were in replay?
Can you raise your hand?
Kudos to you. You were able to make the
morning session.
My manager has to push me out of the
replay to come to the session, you know, like
have a good night's sleep.
OK, let's dive deep into it now. OK,
so I'm gonna talk,
uh, what deployment strategies
and what provision we did for
fine-tuned model.
We'll talk about the architecture deep dive.
There are some
222 main modules. One is
large language model, a foundation,
and another one is vision,
language model.
And third one, we'll talk about one of
the notebook sample where you can actually
see the code, uh,
especially the machine learning engineer, they want
to see how easy it is to fine tune a
model. So let's do that one, OK?
So. Good.
So there are 2 choices or 2 flavors you can
fine tune a Nova model.
One is on sage maker training jobs, and
the second one is sage maker hyperpod.
So which one to choose, that depends
on use case
and also how much
data and how long you're going to train the job.
For our experiments, our training
jobs were
running for 3 hours on
P548X large GPU
using 4 GPUs,
and
we didn't want to use the cluster. We
wanted to make like quick dirty runs like super
fast, so we used sage maker training jobs.
But in production, if you have data for
like 5 years and you want to train on
like several GPUs, several 100 GPUs,
and for weeks,
so Sage Maker Hyperpod is the right tool for
you. There's one small
change like only Sagemaker hyperpod
supports PPO
rates everything is supported by the Sagemaker
training jobs.
As Aid explained, just to recap
this one for large first approach, LLM,
how we tackle the forecasting
using foundation model.
We use two LLMs.
First one was
Cloud Sonnet 3.7,
and we compared
the output with NOAA Pro 1 model.
OK. NOAA Pro 1
has better
accuracy for this weather forecast, and it
was not fine tuned. It was just
doing the simple prompts
and process data.
So if I show you here
the weather sensor data,
it is being picked up over here, the raw input
of the grid data, what does that mean, raw
input grid data for us
is you have a
multi-dimensional array
and that xy will say like core latitude
longitude.
And one value will be maybe
one of the weather attributes will have a value like amplitude.
So you have sea wave height, right?
So at certain geographical
location you will see the latitude, longitude and height
of that wave.
So that is one of the raw grid data. I'll
just give you one example that there are different
aspects.
So let's stick to that. And that data preparation
is done as Edward mentioned,
and we are passing that raw
process data
to the
foundation model.
There's one more thing, if in a sea
region, there is a sea,
um
sorry, there is a weather attribute
to wind direction.
So if in this particular sea region,
if 90% of wind is flowing to
the north direction and 10% is
going northeast,
we'll select that entire region as a north
direction. So that is the
raw data
to the data preparation, and
that we are passing to the foundation model.
Let's dive deep into architecture.
So this architecture is built within 4 weeks
of prototyping phase.
So we have
the raw input grid data.
It's stored in 3 bucket,
as Edward said, it was one run was 45
GB around,
but we had a subset of that,
and for 3 months of data it was roughly
around 86 GB of
numerical data. That's it, 86
GB just for three months and even for a subset.
That's we actually process with ECS
because of a parallel processing.
If someone is running 86
GB of processing on a single code, uh,
it will take like months.
These two ones are optional,
uh, EKS or AWS patch.
It is just for telling like data
parallel processing can be done choosing
one of the three.
Once the data is processed, we are calling the Bedrock
Foundation model
and output we are storing into the S3 bucket.
Here I want to highlight this architecture is
really, really good to process large volume
of historic data.
Foundation model
through the bedrock mostly
supports the batch in front,
but you need to check which model supports the cloud
family supports, Nova family supports.
So this saves a lot of time and it
it it saves a lot of cost as well.
There is one small caveat
when you are using fine-tuned model, but I will
explain that when we go to the VLM one,
OK, just keep that in your note.
This is very flexible because you are
using ECS and under the hood you can
use EC2 instead a target based on
how much complete power you want to give,
and
there's one thing in this architecture that is lacking,
it is the orchestration is manual
as this was a prototype, we had to do like
very quick runs and all, so that's what
we proposed this one
for the production,
OK, and of course for customer
to customer, it changes.
For for this use case, we
had the S3 bucket here. Sorry, my
bad, uh,
yes, I wanted to use the pointer. So
for the S3 bucket we have the data.
We have the AWS glue catalog and
AWS lick formation.
As the organization grows,
teams want to access the data
and to give the fine granular level
access to the data, this data plan
will be really helpful for AWS uh land lake
formation with glue catalog.
Glue catalog is really good if you
want to get a subset of data for
a certain time frame to X to Y,
you can run the query and you can get data very easily.
We are decoupling this architecture using
Amazon SQS.
Decoupling is very important in production
because what if something goes wrong over
here? We need to know
which data is failed,
which, which forecast is not being processed.
So this SQS is very important. We can attach
a dead letter queue also, so if the record
is failed, that's been added to the queue
and the team can go deeper into that.
Data preprocessing block is
The Data preprocesing block is the same, so ECS,
EKS, and batch,
you can use any one of these based on your
need. Some customers use their
workload mostly on EKS, so they, they
prefer to run the processing on EKS. Some
use ECS.
There are other applications, other architecture
I wanted to just walk through it.
What if the
use case uses streaming data?
So we can use Amazon Kinesis data stream.
A lambda is attached for processing.
It depends on how many lambdas
you're going to use. If,
if it's a different processing, one lambda
is output dependent on another, you might use a batch.
And once the data is
processed, which is formatted for the foundation
model, you just call the model. You
store the results in nano DBT and
open search.
Why we are using this, if you want to
do the real-time analysis as well.
Yeah, I want to,
and the last one is erroles event driven
architecture.
Uh, in this one, everything is serless.
When the data is uploaded,
um, once the data is available in S3, it
will trigger a lambda.
It will do the processing using AWS
step function,
and then it will go to the Amazon bedrock and data will be
stored. OK,
now the second module, VLM,
is much more fun.
And
I'm going to tell you the data, how it looks.
So every day
there are 4 times
the forecast is being generated
for 31 sea regions.
In the first forecast
we'll have 31 sea region and
each region will have 5 attributes, 4
or 5 attributes, weather attributes,
and for that one we have to create a video.
So we have and every hour
we are recording the
we are taking the snapshot of the sensor data.
So for 24 hours we have 24
frames like it's converted the raw
grided data to images.
So we have 24 images
for one day
of the call, uh, one day of the,
um, records,
and that we are appending after each other,
and we are creating 1 2nd video
with 24 frames.
That is our
input data,
OK, for training.
And after that
We we're going to walk
through about the architecture diagram.
So this raw input grid data here.
It's stored into S3 bucket
that is being processed, the similar logic, data
parallel processing.
It it created from 86 GB
of raw graded data,
numerical
to
like 56
videos, 56 GBs of video
for 3 months of data.
And also we had to clean some of the data, so
there are some of the incidents where
the two sea regions forecasts were combined. That's
how the expert does it. So we have to skip
that for training purpose.
So that's how in this one we have
the raw training bucket
data in which we have the training data.
Now we use Amazon Sagemaker AI
to submit a NOAA fine tuning job.
Once the training job is completed,
we get the output bucket with Model wax,
and we are hosting that using
Amazon Bedrock.
Now I want to talk to you about two types
of
fine tuning that we experimented.
First one is Lora.
What we do in Lora, we have
a foundation model.
We put the weights like adapter,
and we just fine tune that adapter,
right? That's it, nothing else.
But when you do a full fine tuning
of a foundation model in which you
update the each uh weights of each layer.
And that takes a longer time also, but
it has additional benefit that the model learns
more. Here
when you are using Lora,
you can use the on-demand
inference.
What does it mean on-demand inference for Laura,
because the actual model weight is in
service bucket.
The lower adapter weight is in your
bucket,
in your account,
and when we deploy it, the
lower weights will be appended and the model
will be deployed.
So you can use on-demand inference. You
only pay how many you only
pay for how many input tokens and output tokens
are generated.
However, if you're using
full fine tuning,
what's gonna happen in full fine tuning is entire
model weights is gonna update it.
So that model weight is gonna be stored somewhere
from the original foundation model.
And now the new models which are there, that
needs to be hosted 24 hours
on instance.
So that's why you need to go for a provisional throughput.
You need to buy the provisional throughput so that you can
deploy.
So this is a key difference I wanted to highlight.
So for this one, when we are
using and using this Lora,
we were able to use on-demand in France,
but when we use full fine tuning, we
had to do the provisional throughput.
This architecture was built for
the prototype in 4 weeks.
It is very simple.
It lacks a lot of functionality that can
be used in the production.
So let's go to the production architecture,
how it looks.
We have different planes, data
plane, compute plane, um,
and Sagemer training job plane also.
So data plane, I want to
highlight over here,
just bring your attention.
So we have uh Amazon FS 6
for Lester here also.
So this is added, this is like super
fast access if
you have a requirement that
requires low latency.
The FSX Amazon FXSX cluster
can be used
for caching purpose,
and raises the similar
logic for what we showed
in LLM architecture.
Compute plane is being uh decoupled with SQS
and we are doing computing on ECS
or EKS or AWS patch.
Once the data is being.
Process
all the videos will be stored over here.
So coming back
for one forecast, we have 24
hours of record
pass, so we are creating 24
images.
We are creating one second video out of
the 24 images,
and we have 31 regions.
So we have 31 videos
for one weather attribute
and for one day.
So this is quite big data.
Like a large amount of data,
we use the SageMaker AI.
In this case, you can use SageMaker hyperpods
as well as Sage Maker training jobs in production
based on the need.
Do we really need to go for SageMaker hyperpo?
And then once the model is trained,
the weight should be stored into Amazon S3,
and then we are deploying it on the bedrock.
Why we are deploying it on bedrock, the first question comes,
why what it gives additionally, because
once the model is on bedrock,
all the, almost all the features
available for bedrock, you can use it on that model.
You can use the uh you can use
the bedrock converse APA
without changing anything. You just need to change the
idea of a model,
and it, it works.
If you, if you want to use the guard rails, you
can use that also.
So that gives that undifferentiated heavy
lifting
over here.
Uh
There are alternate architecture. I just wanted to
walk through it.
The first one is
model fine tuning.
It's simple.
UR data in S3 bucket. Why we are taking
everything in S3 bucket because it scales really
well and
uh with AKS and ECS, it
actually pulls it pretty cool, like
pretty fast.
Once the data is there, uh,
the data is processed, it stores into the
S3 bucket again,
and we are using the Sage maker or hyperpo
to train. And we are deploying it on
the inference.
Second one, how we will be calling
that model.
Because in VLM there is a huge amount of
data processing.
For example,
when the data is in.
This might take at least
a minute to process, to create a video,
because the the raw graded data needs to be
picked up, it needs to be cleaned,
then it's converted to the images,
and then it it goes to the video.
So it takes a little bit of time,
and once it is done,
we will call the Amazon Bedrock
to to get the entrance.
The easiest way, this this part,
why not we host it on Amazon Sagemaker
endpoint? Why you are using Bedrock,
or why we can't host it on Amazon EKS?
If you have an open source model like
from huggingpa Sumol V3,
you can do that one. You can fine tune that model
and you can host it on Sagemaker
Endpoint,
or you can host it on Amazon EKS also.
We had the LLM and VLM part.
Now how we wanted to show it on UI
is real quick.
If you
are if the application is hosted
and accessible to the public
internet, you use a cloud front with API
gateway and AWS Lambda,
and decouple architecture with SQS
and it will call the Amazon Bedrock or Sage
Maker or EKS.
The another approach is, uh, you put cloud
front, you have application load balancer,
your static website or um your
easy to insert website is is is behind
that one.
sorry, Amazon Container Service,
and then
through that one you will call the um
Sage maker AI or EKS or Bedrock
for press.
We are the Amazon app runner as also Amazon Amplified
to host your website.
Now let's go into the notebooks.
I will ask very difficult question
now. How
2 questions. How many of, how
many of you
has fine tuned a large language model or
any foundation model?
Raise your hand, don't shy.
OK, now a difficult question.
Were you able to get it in the first attempt
to fine tune
or, uh, no, cool,
that's it. So now I'm telling you
this one,
I ran like 25 experiments
and one or two was failed because
I had to stop it because the training data was missed from
my side. It runs very smoothly,
OK? Now how the training data
looks like.
So I just want you to pay attention over here.
The system is a system prompt, OK,
it says you are an expert.
In meteorological specialized in UK
maritime. OK,
this is our
user prompt. We should analyze this one
second video and do this, this,
this. And this
is our input data.
Uh, this is the, you say
Biscay is the sea region, and this is
one of the one of the weather attributes.
This is our input video,
and this is
the ground route, our output.
That's it.
If you have 3000 examples like
this, it creates one JOL file
with 3000 lines,
and this is getting flattened as one line.
So that is our training data.
We create training data set as well as
the validation data set when you are fine tuning
a model. OK.
How you will configure for fine tuning a model
like what is this?
What is the recipe file? So people who doesn't
know the recipe file is just like a configuration
for hyperparameterss.
So in this one, if you see, we give
them which model we want to fine tune.
Replicas is around how many GPUs
you want to train.
We say the training configuration, how many epochs
if there are
you want to control the
regulation parameters.
Uh, Optimizers, there are a bunch of
optimizers available out of the box.
You can use it straight away, and this is a Lora
configuration adapter.
That's it. And you need
this YAML file and a training script.
Now let's see how difficult is the training script.
OK? For me it was very hard, but
let's see. Cool.
It's very simple
Here we define our Yamal file.
OK. Input
data, as I told you, there is trend.json
file, for example, I select 3000 lines
just on file.
We output bucket where we want to store
the model weights.
Validation is 3
validation, Jason. OK,
I want to pay attention over here a little bit on validation.
Whenever you are fine tuning a model,
que validation data set.
Why? Because the model will
try to
optimize on a training data set.
It will always go the training loss low,
low, low, but on actual data it
might go up.
So you need to find a sweet spot where
training data,
training loss, as well as validation loss is
going down.
But as soon as validation loss is going up,
you need to stop your training.
OK? Just keep that in mind.
And this one is image URI.
This is a docker image,
OK? And it runs very smoothly. There
is no issues on the library
configuration.
It runs as smooth as possible.
Then instance type is P548 X large.
For NA fine tuning, you can use
P5 and P6 as well,
and there is a recommendation in instance count is
48, and 16.
You can add tensor bird output
when you're fine tuning a model as well.
Now we create an estimator.
This is just like giving all the
information what was there,
and here we get the input,
the training input,
validation input, and we say fit
the model. Within
3 hours, the model will be trained.
That was for our data.
Now how to
deploy that model.
We have
here Bedrock line create custom model, so
it will create a custom model as in
it will get the model weights,
OK? And this one create custom
deployment means it will deploy on Bedrock.
It will take an hour or so to
to do everything.
So I want you to pay attention to the custom deployment
ARN. This is kind of model ARN
or model ID.
Now, how we will get the inference?
This is a magic codes.
So we have the Bedrock runtime converse API.
We give the model ID.
This is a custom deployment AN
system prompt, which was you are an expert in
UK meteorology.
User prompt, analyze that 1 2nd video.
This is a
uh input video URI S3 bucket,
and that's it.
And it will give the output.
And this is the ground root.
So it is, it is very close to this one.
So, uh, here, uh, we,
we did a lot of experiments
around 2025 experiments we did,
and we, we did experiments with
Thalora as well as, uh, self fine tuning,
like fine tuning the entire model,
and that's where that experimentation
and the model of the evaluation
will be run by Edward, so I'll, I'll hand it over
to you. Uh, thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you.
Great.
Thanks Dinesh.
So having discussed the architecture, we'll
just talk briefly about some experiments
and evaluations that we conducted
er to further optimize our
particularly presentation of the information
er to the foundation model.
So
these experiments in Nova fine tuning
boiled down to four things.
Firstly, we were looking at combined versus
individual models.
We were looking at continuous versus
categorical data that's provided to these.
We were looking at overfitting versus simulation
of overstopping.
And finally, as Dinesh also
mentioned, uh, full rank fine tuning
versus uh versus Laura
approaches.
Again, just to recap,
er for our
um LLM experiments, this
was using
um
the Nova Pro model um
without any fine tuning for our
um
VLM approaches,
then this was using the Nova Light model er
with er with the fine tuning as
er Dinesh has just
described. So
into some of these experiments then.
First of all, we considered how we're
formatting these videos.
So it's attractive on the face of it, to
have just a single video that we're providing
with all of the information about all of the weather
attributes.
Um, so clubbing together each of
the parameters of interest, so for
example, wind speed, wind direction, visibility,
weather type, uh, sea state into
a single 5 2nd video.
But actually, what we found was that
if we're instead breaking
these down by individual attributes and training
models for each of these, then actually we
get a much better result and
the individual models were outperforming
a combined model by on average
about 2. 7%,
because we've got increased opportunity
in terms of uh in terms of
the prompts that we're providing,
increased control in terms of how
we're we're doing this, and uh
there's not so much context switching
uh taking place on that.
The next question was actually how
we're presenting this meteorological data
to the model itself.
So typically, uh we
consider, for example, uh fields
of sea state, so our wave height
is effectively a map of how high
the waves are, with that height being
a numeric representation.
But given the specific language of the shipping
forecast,
we actually have an opportunity to categorize
these into the particular bands that correspond
to this particular terminology.
And again,
changing the color scales from
just a continuous color scale uh for
the videos that were provided to these banded
categorical values that correspond to the
specific terminology of the shipping forecast,
again, enabled us to achieve
further improvements with our categorical
data models typically outperforming the continuous
models uh by on average
about 25.4%.
And if you drill a little bit deeper into
this, actually the biggest
improvements um are in areas
such as the weather type, where
previously just a numeric text
label has no real meaning,
uh, but actually when we're converting this and labeling
this on the y axis or our color scale
on the videos that we're providing,
we can provide,
uh, this additional
information to, to, to help.
What was quite an
unintuitive result in many ways,
was that in our experiments of overfitting
versus early stopping,
the overfitting outperformed the
early stopping,
despite these having a higher validation
loss. And if we trace this back, this
is due to a discrepancy between
the training objective that we were using
in training, compared to our evaluation
approach. And really, the overfitting
is enhancing the memorization of precise
word pattern. Which is specific in the shipping forecast,
and there and therefore produces
more confident output, so it increases
our word-based F1 scores,
giving more accurate and more complete forecasts.
But the early stopping, which optimizes
this embedded probability or perplexity,
fails to capture
these types of wants.
And the final experiment that we'll
talk about um relates to
this full rank fine tuning
versus uh the the low
rank adaption.
And what we saw was that typically our full rank
uh fine tuning is outperforming
the use of the adapter in these experiments
by about 6.2%
um across our
uh our models.
As Dinesh explained.
The law approach is basically applying
an adapter to the pre-trained weights
that then enable us er to
make er these adjustments. But
it's worth just drilling a little bit deeper
um into some of the characteristics of these
approaches and particularly some of
the er.
The the cautions in terms of using,
uh using some of these approaches,
particularly compared to a full weight fine tune.
So fundamentally, if the model
has to perform only a single narrow
task,
full model training can still have a
performance advantage. We're very closely
optimizing it um to learn
that very specific er behavior.
In contrast,
Laura will learn less, and
I'd refer you to the paper by er
Dan Bidderman et al. which describes
this in er in nice detail.
But Laura learns less, but also
it forgets less.
So with full model fine tuning,
you can risk catastrophically forgetting
the other capabilities that haven't
been represented in the, in the training data
set. So you can effectively just overwrite
this um with er with
er with catastrophic effect
if you're not careful.
There is, however, um.
Compromise in uh in some of this
space, and as Dinesh said, we were applying
this LA adapter just to the final
layer of the model.
However, there's some recent evidence to suggest
that instead of just applying it to that
final layer, applying a L
adapter to each layer of the
network uh could significantly
increase performance, albeit at the cost
of increased latency.
Um, however,
this would provide a more regret-free
approach, uh, to being able to,
uh, to be able to tune these approaches using,
using law-based, uh, methods,
and in contrast to the full fine
tuning, if you're also increasing the learning
rate as well, could potentially,
uh, achieve,
um, parity of er
of performance in in that space,
um, as well.
It's also worth mentioning just in the context of
some of the announcements this week er that
some of the capabilities of Nova Forge as well
might offer additional opportunities
for being able to er comprehensively
er tune these types of approaches er
in future.
So,
having talked a little bit about some of the experiments
and some of those opttimisations, I think it's also
worth touching on the evaluations. And I've
mentioned, for example, some of the F1 based
uh metrics that we'd used, um, and I'm
just going to dive a little bit more
deeply into these
before presenting
the final model comparisons.
So throughout our experiments, we used
word-based F1 scoring.
So as we heard right at the start,
the text of the shipping forecast is highly
specific and it's structured in its nature,
so it doesn't leave much room for creative
writing. We therefore wanted
to use a direct comparison metric,
so we're
counting the number of matching words,
the number of missing words, the number of extra
words
between the generated text and
the expected text.
And I'm showing an example of this just here. So
for example,
if our expected text relating to
the wind characteristics was northeast
veering southeast 3 to 5,
and our generated text was east
or northeast,
3 to 5, uh, then we've got
4 true positives, 2 false negatives,
2 false positives in this,
giving an overall F1 score
of 67%.
Now an alternative approach that other people might
have considered might have been using, for
example, a BERT score.
So this is an alternative to a word-based
precision recall, um, but it
provides a much softer match between the
words,
resulting in an overly lenient impression
of performance in applications such as
the Shipping Forecast where
um extreme precision is required.
So for example, using that same
uh case that I just showed for the Word-based
F1 score that we used,
uh, if this was a word, if this was a BERT-based
score,
then rather than having um.
Rather than having a result of 67%
accuracy as we, we were measuring here,
you would result in, um, in,
in a performance of about 86%,
which is a little bit misleading.
And really to drill down into why these types
of approaches are so misleading, um, is
if we consider, just for example, the word
uh north and south.
So obviously, geographical direction is fundamental
in communicating where weather systems
are coming from.
Um, but if we generated an expected
word uh north.
And the, sorry, if you had an expected
outcome of north and the generated word was
south,
then actually,
this would result in a BERT score of 82%,
despite this having
the complete opposite geographical meaning, and
this is because it's working on the embedding level rather
than on that word
word level in the score.
So. I thought I'd mention that just as a word of caution
in terms of evaluating these types of approaches,
but also to demonstrate the strictness and the robustness
that we applied to these
experiments,
because we're literally comparing to
what the
expert meteorologists issued in
their bulletins
and counting those words on that
basis.
Now, as Dinesh also mentioned, we
considered some comparisons between the Nova
Pro model uh and the Claude 3.7
Sonet model, um, for,
uh, the LLM uh comparisons.
And again, as Dinesh mentioned, there
was a difference in in performance, um,
with the Nova Pro scoring
an average uh Word F1 score of 62%
to Claude 3.7 Sonnet of 57%.
Um, and significantly,
from an operational perspective, um,
at a, at a, at a cheaper cost.
But I wouldn't drill too much into the
actual numbers here, because as we know,
within this field,
foundation models are being released all
the time, and this is, this is only,
uh, only growing.
So the main thing to take from this, and as it relates
to the architecture that Dinesh talked
about at the start.
Is the great thing about having architected
this in Bedrock,
means that actually, as new models are
released, so for example, uh Cloud
4.5 sonnet,
then actually it's just a one line change
within our uh within our code to
then be able to test this with a new model. And
depending on our application, we might find some
perform better or worse, but we have
this complete flexibility uh to
be able to take advantage of new models,
um, as they're as they're released on
this, uh, basis.
It's also worth saying something a bit about
the uh LLM versus
uh the VLM uh comparisons
here.
Now, with our LLM based approach,
we were providing uh information
to that through a through a text uh
intermediary,
um, and we were able to provide a little bit of extra
information uh due to the way we were able
to format some of these experiments, and it was on
uh the Nova Pro rather than uh the
Nova Lite model.
In comparison, our VLM approach
used, for example, a more simple
representation of some of our probabilistic
information, and this could be significantly improved,
um, but nonetheless, we're getting
scores compared to the human.
Meteorologists written bulletins of
between 52 and 62%,
and the opportunities for evolving this, particularly
in the VLM space,
is particularly significant, and we think that this is
going to be key going forwards in terms of
reducing some of the information bottlenecks
that would otherwise be associated with
providing
information to LLMs through a through a text intermediary
stage as well.
So just to summarize then, some
of the key learnings uh from this.
Fundamentally, we've evolved a pattern
for architecting scalable AI
solutions with considerations of alternatives,
advantages and disadvantages that
can be applied to er this
type of data to text conversion
um that applies to so many
of the types of products and services that we
er deliver at the Met Office.
Also,
uh, this provides a framework for rapid
experimentation, um, and enhancement.
As Dinesh mentioned,
all of this work was conducted within a four-week
period, from spinning up the environment,
uh, to conducting, uh, the evaluations,
um, and, and assessments. So
it just shows the types of velocity that you can
work at both, uh, within,
within these, but also with uh working
practices and, uh, support from er the
team at Amazon.
Fundamentally, we were looking at comparisons
of uh LLM based approaches
versus VLM based approaches.
And as I said, the LLM performs better
because we're able to apply some of the extra domain knowledge
that we're able to simplify some of its input.
But these textual data
descriptions do represent an
information bottleneck.
So in the future, we're anticipating
that the VLM will actually outperform the
LLM on this task,
um, and we've got some exciting steps
to implement to be able to move forward
on this.
Finally, we talked in uh
in length around some of the fine tuning
experiments that were conducted, and
particularly the use of Laura versus full
fine tuning.
So Laura learns less,
so for specialized applications, then actually
uh full model training could
have a performance advantage,
but it also forgets less, so you risk
the or reduce the risk of catastrophic
failure. And as I said, some of the really
emergent. Research at the moment
suggests that applying this to each layer in the
model could give a regret-free approach,
and there are further considerations and opportunities
associated with the Nova Forge framework which
might provide
an additional basis um for
this. I'll
leave this uh up here at the moment, so
really just bringing it all together. We've
got the full architecture diagram that we used
for the prototype on the left-hand side.
On the right hand side, we're just showing some of
the interface uh and it's recording
the interface for the er LLM
based approach
that provided us a means of being able to expose
this to some of our users.
And really excitingly, uh we're moving.
Forward with actually
being able to provide some of these outputs
for evaluation by our meteorologists,
not just applied to the shipping forecast, but
applied to similar
workflows as well. So
we're really looking forward to this.
Just incidentally, what we're seeing here on the left hand
side is we've loaded in
the shipping forecast bulletin, this is for evaluation.
Uh, we're running the LLM task here and
we can see the progress, uh,
that is associated with this,
um, as it's running, um, in
this case, they say it's the, the LLM
task.
Um, and then on the right hand side we'll start
to see the, uh, the, the
result returned, um, from,
uh, from the LLM,
uh, corresponding to the shipping forecast that
then gives us, uh, this
opportunity,
um,
opportunity for, uh.
For, for evaluation,
um,
on, on that.
So we can see this is now generated on the
right hand side.
We can compare this directly to
the bulletin that was written by the
meteorologists,
but we can then also apply
our scoring based on these comparisons
so we can actually evaluate the performance
of This, which will then feature
in the tasks at the bottom
down here. So within this same interface
we're just able to start to
engage
some of those types of interested
interested users
on this basis.
And then finally at the bottom
we're just generating
some of the
Well, we're generating opportunities
for sort of translation, obviously as a national meteorological
Service, then
then being able to provide data in different or input
in different languages is obviously off the shelf
capability of these types of models,
and we can see the output for human reference
that was generated
there. I'd
just like to conclude um by
thanking, thanking you for being here, as Dinesh
said, um, really appreciate it
after, after replay,
um, but also I'd particularly like to thank
uh the team from uh the specialist
prototyping team from AWS.
Uh, whose support on this has been
absolutely fantastic, um, and absolutely
fundamental to, to unlocking this,
uh, so thanking Dinesh, also
Emilio and Lewis and Emir who couldn't
be here today, um, and Kanda, um,
who's the team leader as well.
Finally, I'd just like to say please do
provide any feedback
on this via the survey in the
mobile app.
That would be much appreciated.
Um, and if anybody wants to chat further,
um, afterwards, we'll be at the back
and, and very happy to pick up questions.
Also point you to
on archive this week we released a
paper describing in more detail
some of these experiments that were conducted.
So if you're interested in that, please speak to Dinesh Ryan.
We'll be pleased to provide that
link. Many thanks.
Thank you so much.